DAVE MARX: Jack Garratt.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE MARX: Let's have
a nice conversation.
I was working on
my accent, you see.
JACK GARRATT: This
chair is [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE MARX: Yeah, pretty
good [INAUDIBLE].
So Jack, thank you
so much for coming.
It means so much to us.
[INAUDIBLE]
JACK GARRATT: Thank
you for having me.
DAVE MARX: Yeah.
And now, so your
debut album, "Phase,"
you just released it
about a month ago.
The reactions have
been phenomenal.
If you guys haven't listened
to the whole album through yet,
you absolutely have to
because it's unreal.
But this wasn't your
first music-making foray.
You've been making music
for a very long time, right?
I even watched some
old videos on YouTube
of you playing songs
off "Nickel & Dime,"
and the acoustic guitar.
Can you tell us how Jack
Garratt in this form came to be
and how long it's
been around for?
JACK GARRATT: Essentially,
about four or five years ago, I
woke up and realized I
wasn't happy with anything
about myself.
It was a great moment.
In the same way
that, like-- I feel
there's a kind of decade in
which you have that opportunity
to have that realization.
It's from like the
age of 18 to like 28.
And it's in that
time at some point
you have to realize
that you suck.
And then the day after
that, you can go, OK.
Cool.
I suck.
That's great.
I'm now going to
be better at stuff.
A lot of the album has come
out of that way of thinking.
You cannot have light
without darkness.
You cannot have something
shining in your face because it
needs to have darkness to be--
in the same way you can't have
darkness without light, because
otherwise neither of those
things exists.
You cannot know what happiness
is unless you've experienced
sadness.
Those two things are
equally as important,
and that's a realization I
made when I was about 19.
And I had this album.
And I'd recorded an album and
I'd been working really hard
and I woke up and I went,
I hate all of the songs.
I genuinely don't
like any of them.
And I'm not enjoying the
course I'm on at university.
I'm not enjoying
myself as a person.
How can I change that?
And five years later, I finally
feel like I'm ready to go,
I'm OK.
DAVE MARX: I totally
understand where you come from.
It didn't sound right to you.
You were making music maybe
that other people liked,
but it wasn't meeting
your standards.
JACK GARRATT: Yeah, that wasn't
another big thing, as well.
The kind of relationships
that I had at that time,
not just-- with all kinds of
people-- not with my family.
My family have always
been the most kind
of supportive and consistent
group of people I've ever
had in my life, but like
other paternal figures
I had in my life.
Other maternal figures
I was surrounding
myself with people
who were fueling and supplying
the demand that their ego was
giving them and using
me as a way to do that.
I had a guy who would really
regularly give me gigs,
and I thought it
was out of support.
Like, he gave me my first
ever show when I was about 14,
and I thought it
was out of support.
And I very quickly
came to realize
that he was doing it because
he saw a potential and saw
talent in something very
young and essentially was
the first person-- like invented
[INAUDIBLE], but with people.
He would put me on
that show because he
knew that it would sell
tickets because people
wanted to come and see me.
And this is not me blowing
smoke up my own ass, I promise,
but they wanted to come and
see a 14-year-old kid who
played blues guitar and sung
those kind of bluesy songs
and stuff.
I just kind of, for
some reason, was
very attracted to
being used in that way,
which is a weird thing.
It was very strange.
And again, the realization
of that was pretty great.
DAVE MARX: I think that's
the theme I actually
get from your album of this.
It's a bit self-deprecating
and self-degrading,
but to me, my interpretation is
there's a lot of things in me
I want to work on, but it's
not because I think I'm bad.
It's because I want
to get better for you.
JACK GARRATT: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] for
the other person.
And a lot of my songs
kind of deal with that.
[INAUDIBLE] I love
the feeling you
have as a person, where you
sacrifice so much of yourself
for the sake of someone
else, but really you're
just showing off.
Really, you're just
doing it because you
want to be able to say,
I'm a martyr for you.
And that person's going,
I don't know who you are.
And that was a really constant
battle I had with myself,
where I would
pretend to be people
I wasn't to impress
people who didn't care
about me in the first place.
A lot of my songs kind
of deal with that idea
of self-sacrifice for the
sake of self-obsession.
DAVE MARX: And I think that's
sort of the "Remnants" EP--
the idea of, I'll destroy myself
trying to get you to notice me,
and you might not
even know who I am.
JACK GARRATT: Exactly.
It's the reason why
a lot of my songs
deal with the idea of death,
because you sit there and go,
I don't want to die.
Not because people will miss me.
I'm going to miss myself.
It is that very immature way of
looking at the way that things
exist, and the end things,
and the beginning of things--
just the natural phase and
the natural progression
and the natural
[CLICK] [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE MARX: [INAUDIBLE].
JACK GARRATT:
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, it's something
I think about a lot.
It's something I,
for some reason,
really enjoy writing about.
The other thing I really, really
like about that way of writing
music as well is I write,
my lyrics especially,
I write kind of as letters
to people or for people,
not necessarily for
myself, but just a letter
from one person to another.
And the great thing
about having the songs
and having that
kind of discussion
be presented in that way
is a letter, on its own,
drops you somewhere in the
middle of a conversation.
You don't know how
many letters have
been exchanged back and forth.
You're just looking at one.
That's what my song
[INAUDIBLE] just one letter out
of a conversation.
So it drops you in the
middle of a conversation
you know nothing about, and
then puts you deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper
into the conversation
and then never resolves
it because you never get
an answer back from the person.
So my songs are kind of just
like, hey, here's an emotion.
Here's me exploring
that emotion,
and now you're in a hole.
And I'm sorry, I've
run out of ladders.
I don't want to know
why I have a lot of fun
writing about that kind
of really uplifting stuff.
DAVE MARX: We love to listen.
Is there a song off
this album that you'd
say is your proudest work?
JACK GARRATT: I
wouldn't say it's
a song that's my proudest work.
There's lots of
songs that I admire
for lots of difference reasons.
It's good to admire
your own work.
It's good to enjoy
the thing that you do.
It's the same in anything,
especially creative,
and especially
creative in business.
If you don't enjoy the
thing that you're creating,
then the substance,
the purpose, of it
kind of disappears, so I
make sure that everything I
release-- everything that is
listened to by other people--
is something that I would want
to listen to as a fan of music.
And for that reason, I
like the music I make.
So for that reason,
I enjoy a lot
of the songs on this record
for different reasons.
Kind of in the conversation that
we've just been having, track 3
I think it is, "Far
Cry," is I think
the deepest I go
in terms of what
we were just talking about.
But there's other
songs on it that I
like for different reasons.
Like "The Love You're Given" is
one of the first songs I really
probably produced and sat down.
It's a couple years
old, that song.
One of the first songs
I really sat down
and produced and mixed
it and did it myself
and then kind of sent off.
DAVE MARX: That was kind of the
first song of this new saga,
where you were doing
electronic and doing
the songwriting and the
mixing at the same time.
JACK GARRATT: Yeah,
because first EP,
"Remnants," was a lot
more songwriter-based
and then the second
EP was me kind
of trying to get a hold of my
production trying to figure out
what it meant to be a producer.
I've never gone to
school to study music.
I've never had someone tell
me what my compression is.
I remember doing music
technology at school because I
was like, hey, computer games.
That will be fun for
two years, as a joke.
And then that's essentially
what it ended up being.
The teacher I
didn't really know--
Anything that is not to say--
I have a really, really good
education.
I've really good
relationship with my teachers
because I wanted to.
You want to admire
your peers and you
want them to admire
you, and you need
that kind of basic
level of mutual respect
to be able to learn
from each other.
But unfortunately the
subject wasn't well-funded
and we didn't have a lot
of stuff to work with,
so I went and did-- this
was like when I was 17,
so doing my A-levels, like
college or university--
but I went and I
remember like a week
before we were supposed to
go in and do our final exam,
I had a conversation with
another friend of mine
who was studying music
tech at another school,
and he told me about
this magical thing
called compression.
Musicians in the room
maybe kind of understand
how important it is to have
that in recorded music.
None of us knew.
We'd been studying it
for about a year and 1/2
and it was our final
exam coming up,
and I suddenly
come into the room
and go, what's compression?
And everyone goes, duhh.
Our teacher comes back with a
two-page Wikipedia printed out
description of what
compression is and goes, there.
DAVE MARX: And would the right
way to describe to people
in the room who
don't know what it
is, making the loudest
parts and the softest parts
come closer together?
JACK GARRATT: It's so you
don't have-- it just cleans up.
You have to kind of put it on a
lot of the individual tracks--
vocals, drums, bass, everything.
It all needs to be
compressed to a point
so that they can sit
against each other
and it all makes a nice sound.
It's not like an obvious
effect that you hear.
It's just something that's
there to clean everything up.
It's really necessary.
DAVE MARX: [INAUDIBLE]
you'd have your real house
to be self-producing
albums where you are.
JACK GARRATT: Yeah, exactly.
And so when I started producing
my music after I left school
and after I tried
to go to university,
I started to teach
myself worse things
because I realized
suddenly I didn't have
the teaching anywhere else.
But it's the same with
instruments and everything.
I've always found that
I teach myself in a way
that I can respond
to rather than
if someone else teaches me.
But if someone else teaches me
and gets me excited about it,
I sponge and I just
collect all the information
and it just soaks in me.
DAVE MARX: And so you're
a self-taught musician
putting out the album
completely by yourself.
I've seen an interview
where you describe yourself
as of a perfectionist who
doesn't believe in perfection.
And I saw an interview
from last week
where you said songs from
the head and the heart,
but that you play
with the hands.
Do your songs accurately
represent the way
you hear them in your head now?
Are you able to
present them in a way
where it actually sounds
like you want it to do this?
JACK GARRATT: Well, yeah,
because I kind of know
exactly what sounds
I'm going to make,
and I also have no idea what
sounds I'm going to make.
It's a weird balance of
those two exact things.
You know exactly
where you want to go,
but you don't know what it is.
I don't quite know how to
explain it, but in the same way
I've said before, I've never
produced a song that I've
sat there and listened
to the end of it
and gone, hm, just not
sure about that one bit.
That's never happened because
if I'm not sure about it,
I've said to
everyone, I'm sorry.
I know the deadline
is in 5 minutes,
but you're going to have to
wait another couple of hours
because I've got
something to fix.
The most important
thing is making sure
that what I'm
outputting is the best
that I can be in that moment.
Not the best that I can be
in comparison to anyone else.
I don't try and
compete in music,
because music isn't elitist.
It's not competition.
It's an art form.
I just try and better
myself and be the best
that I can be in that moment.
I always know what
I'm going to hit.
I just have no idea
what it is yet.
DAVE MARX: I'd like to
open it up to the audience
with the few minutes left.
AUDIENCE: First, thanks so much.
Unbelievable.
I just wanted to dig
into the writing style
as it pertains to how
you do a live set.
Do you kind of
write it as you're
going with the idea of
that live set in mind
or do you deconstruct
a finished product?
JACK GARRATT: A little of
column A, a little of column B.
I started off just
kind of writing songs
because I'd written all
these songs acoustically,
and I kind of taught
myself to write music
while playing acoustic
guitar, and then
I kind of realized
that I was having
more fun producing those songs.
And that was kind
of the first thing,
was deconstructing the music
I'd written acoustically
and then putting my
producer's hat on and sitting
in front of my computer and
having all my other things
around me and then producing
it into an electronic piece
of music or whatever genre
was taking me at that moment.
The next step was then trying
to find a way to play it live.
When I did the first run of
shows a couple years ago,
it was, OK, so if I
wrote these songs,
I need to find a way to
play them life and I'm poor,
and I don't have a band,
and I don't have the time
to have a band, but I have
loads of shows coming up.
And I knew that I'd be able
to do something like this
because ever since
I was little I've
been able to do lots
of different things
when it comes to music.
So that was a case of going, OK.
I've got to be strict
on myself and I've
got to find a way to
deconstruct the music
and represent in the best way
possible in a live situation.
When the record came
out, I had already
been digging like this
for a couple of times,
so I did start
thinking, oh my god,
how am I going to
play this live?
If I was asking
myself that question,
I knew I was on the
right path for the song.
I sitting there
going, this is crazy.
I have no idea how I'm going
to be able to do all of this.
And then I said, well,
don't worry about it yet.
You're on the right line.
If you're questioning
yourself about that right
now, then surely
that's a good thing.
It's like, I don't
have seven arms.
OK, let's see if we
can get seven arms.
AUDIENCE: Which tools are you
using to write and record?
And when you're on
the road, do you also
write music, recording,
what do you use?
JACK GARRATT: I actually
still use Logic 9.
Yeah, it's a couple
of generations
old because I don't like
change and I'm terrified.
I've just heard nightmares
about the relationships
between those programs
and the laptop I'm using,
the software updates
and everything.
So I'm running on an older
version of everything.
And that's kind of what I use
for all of my recording stuff.
I did most of the
record in the box.
I did most of it on my laptop on
the road, in the back of vans,
in the back of cars,
on buses, and stuff
like that because I was touring
and trying to finish an album.
And then I had like a
two-week period where me
and a really good friend of
mine, the engineer who actually
worked on the entire record and
kind of co-produced a lot of it
and finessed a lot of it with
me-- a guy called Brett Cox.
We spent two weeks in this
small studio in London
doing all of the extra bits.
Like, I kind of demoed
these ideas on my laptop
and get them to a point
where I'm happy with them,
and then he'd come
in and go, cool.
That's a good idea.
Here's a way that you can do
it so it'll have more impact
and it's live.
It's real.
It's existing.
And so we kind of had a lot of
fun playing around with that
in those couple weeks.
In the back of the bus
that I'm driving around
with on this tour, I've got
only room for one speaker,
so I'm doing everything in
mono at the moment, which
is so confusing.
And then my laptop and
a keyboard, and it's
just everywhere I go.
I have it there just in
case something happens.
And I've got my phone
on me at all times,
as well, so if an idea
hits me, just straight
onto recording ideas down.
It's so important,
if you have an idea,
if it comes to you
[SNAP] like that,
it's come to you for a reason.
A lot of artists talk about
the idea of what genius is
and what it means.
I think Tom Waits
and Bob Dylan have
spoken about
[INAUDIBLE] in the way
that actually great philosophers
would think about genius.
It's not something
that you own or have.
It's something that visits you.
It's something
that comes to you.
That's why you can have
those eureka moments.
And it's important hearing
those people talk about it
because Tom Waits says,
if an idea comes to me
and I'm not ready for it, I'll
just say go somewhere else.
Bob Dylan is around the corner.
He'll take it.
But it's important that
if it comes to you,
it's come to you for a
reason, because you're
willing for it to come
to you and also it's
respecting you enough to
visit you, in a sense.
That's kind of how I try
and think about the writing.
So I always have my phone
in case I happen to.
AUDIENCE: So it talks--
your rule for everything
seems to be confidential,
[INAUDIBLE].
I was wondering what's on the
docket for you this summer.
Any festivals you can
let us know about?
JACK GARRATT: I'm just
staring at my manager.
No, there's a couple of
things that are going on.
If I'm honest, I don't
know a lot of it.
I try and know everything I can.
It's important, I think, to
know everything I'm up to
and I'm doing and
stuff, but in terms
of scheduling and calendars,
I get kept out of the loop
because it would
just destroy me.
I know I'm doing a lot.
I know I'm coming back
out to the States.
Is there any-- I'm trying
to think of festivals
that we're doing.
MANAGER: Firefly in June.
You've got a couple
of shows in June
and then Firefly's
over the east coast.
JACK GARRATT: Yeah, so
that's about it for now.
Will you put more in?
MANAGER: Yeah.
JACK GARRATT: That'd be cool.
So yes.
But I don't know.
DAVE MARX: And I'd say,
along with that question,
one I'd like to
end on is what are
you most excited about
coming up, going forward,
whether it's an idea you had
or an event you're playing at?
JACK GARRATT: I'm
actually working
on a lot of different
ideas at the moment,
a bit of passion
projects brewing, which
I'm keeping my voice off of.
I don't what it's
going to be yet,
or how it's going
to manifest, but I'm
creating a lot at the moment.
I'm not a very prolific writer.
It takes me a long
time to write songs.
I'm trying to think.
There were some
from the record that
had taken up to two
years, maybe three years
to write-- to finish.
And at the moment, for some
reason, I'm outputting a lot.
So I'm kind of
encouraged to sing.
I was going to say
that's the reason why
I have a small studio
with me everywhere,
because it seems to be
happening more at the moment.
So I don't know want it
is, but it's definitely not
like anything I've done before.
But then again,
nothing I've ever done
is like anything
I've done before.
I think.
I don't know.
DAVE MARX: Well we look
forward to seeing it.
Guys, let's hear it one
more time for Jack Garratt.